we're gonna get started
a lot of books to mention so I'll make
sure I get them right
sorry we're starting a little late
thanks for all being here and this but
thanks especially to the folks on our
panel mark Skousen Steve Forbes and
George Gilder really pleased that you're
here the for the last I've been a lot of
talk about that over the last generation
maybe the last 40 years really
highlights the challenges of measuring
economic values have been a lot of
people take the view that there hasn't
been much progress much growth in
incomes economic stagnation over that
period of time and I often try to put
the lie to that assertion by asking
people to whether they're low income
middle income high income raise your
hand if you want to go back to 1975 and
the usually aren't a lot of takers but
one thing is undeniable over the last 10
or 15 years we truly have been living
through a period of economic stagnation
and I'm Peter getler I joined the Cato
Institute a year ago
as president and over that time brink
Lindsey in particular has done a lot of
work trying to explore the reasons for
this growth slowdown he's published two
books I have them as books they're
ebooks
one is understanding the growth slowdown
and another is reviving economic growth
for the first time in my life we've had
a ten year period during which real GDP
growth has not reached three percent in
any single year at the time I joined
Cato 13 months ago I was actually
hopeful because during the periods of my
lifetime where we've lived through time
of economic stagnation or or sharp
economic contraction it's created a lot
of pressure tension and anxiety that
often has been the impetus for a
positive change in on the policy front
and I think over the last few months
I've realized that I was
in expecting that economic anxiety would
create some some turmoil and some and
stimulate some change I was wrong
because it's not the kind of change that
I had anticipated clearly we're really
lucky to have three gentlemen here today
that I don't think really need much of
an introduction but I'll try to provide
one between them I think they've
probably written more books than I've
ever read but I think it's a great
opportunity for each of them to comment
on you know their views on how we're
going to revive economic growth in the
United States and thereby continue the
course of progress and prosperity that
our nation has enjoyed for for such a
long period of time and they each have
books that have been released recently
that actually speak to this I spoke with
a donor to Cato recently and he has a
son who will be starting college in the
fall and he told me that he was
considering attending Cato University in
this summer so that his son could be
inoculated against what he was likely to
learn from the economics professors in
college before he attended when I was
getting ready for college I didn't need
such inoculation but in the senior year
of my high school days Jorge guilders
book wealth and poverty was was released
and during the summer between high
school and college I read it and it gave
me no shortage of ammo to use against
the Marxist professors I encountered
when I attended school including in such
classes as capitalism and its critics I
think things have changed some things
haven't changed I think the
philosophical makeup of the faculty at
most universities is about the same as
it was at that time but I felt that in
my classes we were able to engage in
lively debate and disagree without
fearing as many students do today that
it can hurt their grades and a
transcript and the disagreement is
is not not permitted so I actually thank
you George for providing me so much ammo
to use against fraternity brothers
professors and others with whom I I
didn't agree who didn't agree with me
in the case for enterprise and free
markets thanks so much for that thanks
so much for that
George's book is the scandal of money
and we're delighted I think one of the
ideas that Cato has promoted for a long
time is the fact that our fiat money
system and the power the Federal Reserve
is a great threat not only to our
economic well-being but to our freedom
and that's one of the reasons that for
34 years Cato has held a prominent
annual monetary conference that's
coordinated by our vice president Jim
Doran and that we started out of the
direction of George Celgene our Center
for monetary and financial alternatives
to to highlight highlight these risks
and to promote free market alternatives
to our current system so George's book
is very important and timely in addition
Steve's last book I believe was a
similar topic highlighting the threat
that the lack of sound money poses to to
our country so those are both tremendous
contributions to the popular literature
I told Steve earlier that for most of my
life I've not been affiliated with
either major party but that in late 1995
I registered Republican so that in the
1996 Connecticut primary I could cast my
first primary vote for Steve Forbes for
president Steve replied that he wishes a
lot more people
and voted for him but even in defeat he
made great contributions to the to the
debate and the case for freedom
enterprise sound money and a flat tax
and he's still at work his book that he
wrote with Elizabeth Eames reviving
America how repealing Obamacare
replacing the tax code and reforming the
Fed will restore hope and prosperity and
I think he does a fantastic job really
prioritizing three key areas
particularly areas such as health care
and money where many of the problems are
actually created by government
intervention and for some reason the
prescription that many people suggest is
more government intervention finally
mark Skousen who we all know as an
economist an economics professor and
author but many also know as the
impresario of Freedom Fest which he
accurately calls the world's largest
gathering of free minds which takes
place in Las Vegas every summer we're
delighted to have have mark here I
mentioned at the outset that while we
can agree that there's been income and
economic stagnation of late the
measurement problems were reflected in
our economic aggregates I think do fool
us because there many things that aren't
captured in in GDP and I again reject
the assertion that that Americans really
at any linked income level have
experienced stagnation in their
well-being in their lives in the last 40
years
mark has proposed and he now has an
updated version released last year of
his book the structure of production an
alternative to gross domestic product as
a measure of our economy and has
proposed a an alternative called gross
output I'm going to let mark explain it
because one of the reasons rationality
gives for it being a an improved and
accepted version of the measure of the
whose performance is that it's now
published quarterly by the government
along with the GDP figures which is
quite an achievement by mark but I
remind them that as libertarians we
don't necessarily take government action
as an endorsement so I'm looking forward
to to his remarks explaining some of the
work he's done in developing and
promoting more effective measures of
economic performance and we will proceed
with the speakers in the reverse order
by which I introduced them so please
join me in offering a warm welcome to
Cato and Mark Skousen these are your
comments about slow economic growth and
the fact that we haven't experienced 3%
growth and sometimes reminds me of this
this program that George W Bush set up
called the 4% growth plan and when I
talked to the organizer of it I said 4%
growth plan how did he mean growth of
the economy or growth of government so
she didn't appreciate that that comment
but unfortunately under george w bush
the economy never did using standard GDP
statistics never did grow more than or
never did grow 4 percent during the
entire period of full employment so it's
kind of unfortunate what what i'd like
to talk today is what Peter mentioned
gross output I think it's a very
important statistic in fact my main
thesis is that gross output or Gio as we
call it offers a better more
comprehensive picture of the economy is
a powerful unifying force between
accounting finance and economics it
links micro with macro and it appeals to
all the major schools of economics in
many ways geo is the missing piece of
the late what the latest economist calls
the prosperity puzzle which is their
latest issue and it's interesting they
talk a lot in there about the problems
with GDP which
sure will come up in this discussion but
in any case my argument that this is a
unifying approach that it's a more
comprehensive picture of the economy
it's a tall order and so I'd like to get
started I actually see it as a paradigm
shift in the way we treat macroeconomics
so we start off with basics what is GDP
what does it supposed to measure annual
spending is one way of looking at it in
the economy consumers government in
business c plus I plus G is the way they
normally talk about it in classes and
there's a problem with GDP there's a lot
of problems with GDP but the one I want
to focus in particular is according to
GDP statistics what drives the economy
and so what we find out that when you
break down GDP in C plus I plus G you
see that it breaks into consumer
spending as the biggest sector of the
economy government spending second and
business spending a poor third and what
does that say in terms of policy
implications you see that's the issue
and of course because consumer spending
represents such two thirds basically of
GDP you get the media constantly making
creating a myth it's a one of the most
common myths in economics and this is an
example of it from the Wall Street
Journal
you get it from all the publication's
household spending generates more than
two-thirds of total economic output says
The Wall Street Journal so steady
spending gains that is consumer spending
gains should translate into economic
growth if only consumers would spend
more that's all it takes and of course
you have the New York Times consumer
spending makes up more than 70 percent
of the economy and it usually drives
growth during economic recoveries and
finally another one from The Wall Street
Journal consumers are the engine of the
US economy
consumers not producers not
entrepreneurs consumers accounting for
about 70% of the economy so you can see
the problem that's inherent with using
GDP as a statistic is this are we coming
to an accurate conclusion is our
question so we have to ask ourselves the
question what is missing from GDP well
again GDP is C plus I plus G was
eighteen point six trillion dollar
economy is that the economy so we break
it down into consumption 67% twelve
point four trillion dollars investment
three trillion and government three
point two trillion so what is missing in
GDP this is the surprise factor the
supply chain GDP does not measure the
supply chain it does not measure all the
business spending the b2b spending to
bring the products to their final use
you see GDP just measures the value of
finished goods and services your clothes
your shoes the the the internet all of
everything that we're enjoying right now
this cup of water that's all counted in
GDP but the spending by business to get
you to the finished products is left out
and that is its Achilles heel in many
ways and look at the size of that supply
chain which I've been measuring and now
the government is measuring the ve a
Bureau of Economic Analysis twenty point
three trillion dollars it's more than
consumer spending which is twelve point
four it's more than government spending
it's more than fixed see the eye part is
fixed investment now what is gross
output well it can be for those of you
who are economists and you're familiar
with the Irving Fisher's equation of
exchange
it measures total transactions it's also
a measure of Hayek's triangles
and so this is taken from prices and
production this great book that
Friedrich Hayek wrote in 1931 when he
was lecturing at the London School of
Economics and there is a picture of the
triangle that he used now it was purely
theoretical
he has no breakdown is no statistics
backing it it was pure theory and it has
had a rough road of acceptance but what
I'm suggesting is that Hayek triangle is
being measured today now by the
government and this is a fantastic
breakthrough and I am pleased that this
program here today is taking place in
the Hayek auditorium so appropriate
considering the fact that the government
is now measuring Hayek's triangle so we
all know the background of Friedrich
Hayek I just thought I would post this
up here and particularly he's known more
for his book the road to serfdom in the
constitution of Liberty but he has also
authored this macroeconomic work which
formed the foundation of my own work in
the structure production called prices
and production published in 1931 I have
a first edition signed by by Friedrich
Hayek today I've come out or lays a fair
books has published a his two essays on
the business cycle called Hayek's
triangles and they asked me to write the
introduction but here's a modern-day
version of Hayek's triangle where it
shows the four stages of production
resources production distribution and
final output so you can see GDP is in
there but then so are the stages the
supply chain prior to that where we have
stages 1 2 & 3 so this is a great way
for students to capture what Hayek
triangle triangle and what I call the
four state Universal four stage model of
the economy every good and service that
you and I use has gone through the
resource stage the production stage the
distribution or wholesale
he'll stage and then to final use which
is representative number four by GDP
well the big news is in April 2014 the
Bureau of Economic Analysis which puts
out GDP statistics has now started to
measure create gross output a measure of
Hayek strangle or total transactions
under herbing Fisher depending on how
you want to look at that and we have
steveland Feld who is the pioneer as the
director of the be ei who said gross
output provides an important new
perspective on the economy and a
powerful new set of tools of analysis
one that is closer to the way many
businesses see themselves and isn't that
true business sees themselves as
producing moving the product along the
production process and that's what gross
output is measuring so what's really
interesting a lot of people haven't
noticed this but whenever the DEA comes
out with its quarterly promotion
announcements release of GDP data which
they did just recently notice how they
define how they define gross GDP they
define it in terms of gross output first
and then they subtract out intermediate
production so GDP plus intermediate
inputs equals gross output or another
way the way they define it GDP is gross
output minus intermediate inputs so
basically what they're doing is getting
you the audience the consumer of GDP
statistics to get used to the idea of a
what I call a top-line of national
income accounting and a bottom-line the
be EA also for those of us who are
Austrians who believe in disaggregating
the economy and looking at industry by
industry sector by sector I'm delighted
that the beas also introduced gross
output by
industry which allows economists to
disaggregate the economy and based on
stages of production so based on this
announcement I was I wrote a lead
editorial commentary in in April 2014 on
the Wall Street Journal at last a better
economic measure and they came out with
a new third edition of my structure
production basically my book the
structure of production was had
virtually disappeared nobody was reading
it but suddenly when the government
starts using the statistic it has come
out of obscurity and now is being used
in and being read and we have copies
here that for you to to purchase after
the presentation well what can we learn
from the new geo statistic you may ask
yourselves well so what so what that
there's a new statistic well first of
all you can see the gross output from
this statistic is much more volatile
it's a much better indicator of the
business cycle you can see here that
gross output especially during the
recession of 2008-2009 how it dropped
precipitously GDP declined hardly at all
now anomaly terms GDP declined 2% is
that an accurate reflection of what
happened during the Great Recession not
at all but you can see in terms of gross
output you can see what happened in the
intermediate stages there was a
significant drop that is a better at
better evidence of what what is going on
so according to the new model the new
geo model everything is in Reverse
remember in GDP consumer spending was
number 1 followed by government and
business
now suddenly business spending when you
include the supply chain is nearly 60
percent of the economy consumer spending
is now down to 32 percent on instead of
2/3 it's only 1/3 and government
spending is 8.2 percent so when you see
these two models next to each other
what do you see essentially what you see
is that business the business sector is
by far the most important sector in the
economy and policy that Steve Forbes is
talking about in his book and what
George Gilder is talking about in his
book focus on the business sector the
supply chain innovation entrepreneurship
productivity these are the factors and
now we have a model that is consistent
with economic growth theory it's also a
support saves laws Steve hanky says with
GOG DPS monopoly will be broken as the
US government will provide official data
on the supply side of the economy and
its structure so we as supply siders
Austrians we have our own statistic now
I know a lot of you don't like
aggregates but aggregates can tell you a
lot and I love this quote by Larry
Kudlow though not one in a thousand
recognises it it is business not
consumers that is the heart of the
economy when businesses produced
profitably they create income producing
jobs and then consumers spend profitable
firms also purchase new equipment
because they need to modernize and
update other tools structures and
software so this is a new approach I
call it and I'm not saying replace GDP
I'm saying it's complimentary
gross output you know how in a financial
statement you have top line and bottom
line those of us in accounting my
students my business students love this
so we have top line and bottom line top
line is sales and revenue bottom line is
earnings now finally economists have
caught up after a hundred years behind
the times have caught up with the
accounting and Finance professions now
we have a top line we have a bottom line
our top line is gross output revenue in
sales our bottom line is GDP value-added
similar to gross profit in financial
statements and this is a quote here from
three great economists in
reading Stephen Lander felt the be ei
director former be a director and Bill
Nordhaus who is from Yale University in
daily organ sent at Harvard or say gross
output is the natural measure of the
production sector while net output GDP
is appropriate as a measure of welfare
both are required in a complete systems
of accounts so here's a general model of
the economy where you see the production
side the make economy reaching final use
GDP and then consumption when it's used
up and so this is again in my textbooks
a general model of the economy I don't
have time to go into that because I've
run out of time but if you're interested
by the way in in my PowerPoint because
I've gone through pretty quickly
maybe we can send it to the attendees or
they can give me a card or whatever I'd
be glad to to send you this PowerPoint
to give you my basic points gyeo is
being integrated in the text books this
is the sign of success so it's not just
in my textbook which I have economic
logic but it's also in McConnell brew
the number one textbook in the country
although Greg Mankiw disputes that and
we have it in in John Taylor's textbook
and and the and Roger Leroy Miller so
and and David Cole and ER so it's it's
in all of the text books so it's
developing to be in in all of the text
books well I have a few quotes here what
others are saying about it Steve Forbes
has been very supportive in Forbes
magazine feeling that this is a great
leap forward and national income
accounting and George Gilder has
suggested that vital learning
accumulates through all the processes of
production measured in gross output so I
don't have time to read any of the other
quotes but we have the academic
economists we have business economists
and so forth recognizing the value of
the structure of production so my basic
conclusion is simply the structure of
production does matter thank you very
much
we're gonna wait for questions until the
end all I will say mark since you
pointed out that the government now
publishing geo stimulated sales of books
I'm assuming that didn't have anything
to do with your desire for them to
publish it otherwise that would be we
probably count that as rent-seeking I
think supply sales lost supply creates
demand that's what I Mark thanks so much
please join me in giving a warm welcome
to Steve Forbes thank you thank you very
much Peter thank you a Cato
congratulations mark on measuring the
whole economy instead of just part of
the economy but no matter how you
measure the economy there's no getting
around it today it sucks it
it just seems stuck in second gear you
get one good report followed by a
disappointing report
profits aren't what they should be
business investments not what it should
be new business formations are not what
they should be the economy is in a rut
and there's a lot of talk these days
about the new normal that we must accept
this below-average situation Larry
Summers former Treasury secretary former
Harvard president who knows what it'll
be if they're Democrats get in again
talks about secular stagnation as if
some alien forces come along and there's
nothing we human being can do about it
it's all nonsense the rut that we're in
today which is having profound
implications around the world bad
economies lead to bad politics we see
that everywhere around the world
it comes from mistakes and the nice
thing about policy errors is they can be
corrected those errors can be corrected
and that's why we wrote the book
reviving America we focus on three big
reforms obviously there are a lot of
other things that have to be done but
you have to have priorities so we've
prioritized on health care on a new tax
code and getting our
Terri's system back on track for the
first time in almost half a century
health care is an obvious one makes up
almost 20% of the economy but also it's
the most personal thing possible much
more than taxes and the like health care
for us for our families our friends our
loved ones so this leads to the question
why do we have a crisis in health care
it's not the quality of health care in
this country overall it's the best in
the world you can see it in cancer
survival rates Western Europe has many
fine medical institutions but in terms
of survival rates that is five years I
had it several years ago in terms of
five years you do much better in this
country than you do anywhere else in the
world some say it's because there's too
much demand people like me are getting
older we want more health care services
therefore the prices keep going up and
the system goes kablooey but just step
back for a minute and ask ourselves why
is the man for health care considered a
crisis whereas demand for anything else
in this economy is considered a great
opportunity people want more
enlightenment Cato will be glad to help
out it's that good Peter little sucking
up yeah good trying to make sure I get
my free lunch after this and and and and
in in terms of apps you want more apps
right it's glad to help yet you want
more cars Detroit and other
manufacturers glad to come to your
assistance so why is demand for health
care considered a disaster as demand for
anything else in this economy is
considered a great opportunity the
answer is we don't have real free
markets in health care it's all third
party dominated the real customers are
government insurance companies and
employers the patient is at the end of
the line proof of it is because we've
grown up with the system we don't
realize how peculiar it is you go to a
clinic or hospital and you ask in
advance what the treatments gonna cost
get a very strange look means one of two
things either you're uninsured or you're
a lunatic why would you want to know the
price what's it to you don't worry about
it insurance will cover it then we'll
tell how much you owe at the end of the
thing but just be passive about it the
proof of it is another proof of it is
the crummiest motel in america wouldn't
dare put you in a room with another
guest a sick guest with a curtain in
between as they routinely do in a
hospital robes you go to a hospital they
look like they the robes they give you
oh come look like they came from a
Salvation Army dump you know dumpster
that the these things that humiliate you
can't get around you mediate and and in
India and you see them and so the
problems when you have this top-down
system third-party payer system almost
soviet-style system is they always try
to cure the problems with more
regulations but it's like whack-a-mole
one problem comes up you whack it ten
other problems come up whack whack whack
which is why doctors and hospitals spend
more time filling out forms than
practicing medicine while we're having a
doctor shortage no one is happy with the
system we have today medical costs are
still going up you go to a hospital now
that's bad enough but people it's a very
unsatisfying experience you wonder do
the hospitalist as they call them talk
to each other the specialists talk to
each other you tell them to until he
can't have this kind of medication they
give it to her anyway it's an
unsatisfying experience deductibles
under the so-called Obama health care
exchanges yes you may get the insurance
but if health care becomes more
unaffordable than ever because you have
$500,000 deductibles not quite that bad
but it's become out of reach and so
normally in a free-market best practices
are quickly imitated you know iPad
iPhone comes along Samsung and others
say oh we've got a better device a more
improved device you don't get that kind
of thing in hospital just give you one
quick example breast cancer you're
supposed to have mammograms to discover
breast cancer so it turns out if a woman
has dense breast tissue and half the
women do the mammogram and these
so-called improvements on it don't
discover it they only discovered
one-fourth of the time there's a new
practice out there new new treatment
called molecular breast imaging where
they put a tracer in and it will find
breast cancer in women that's why many
times a woman has a mammogram says oh
you're great then a month later they
find out they have a tumor the size of a
baseball why why didn't they find it
because they're now you'd think that
thing like the this new way of
discovering breast cancer molecular
breast imaging MBI
which Mayo in a handful of others been
pushing would be quickly imitated and
saying this is the way to go No
so if you have a mammogram ladies insist
on MBI because otherwise you may miss it
so the key thing is in health care the
key thing is and we outlined it in the
book is getting the patient in control
again for the first time ever as you
know the system came about because of
World War two wage and price controls
they couldn't pay people because the
labor shortages because everyone was
going in the armed services young people
so they paid paid had to pay people in
kind government said you could do it
with benefits rather than cash then
after the war in the 50s of IRS made a
tax ruling that embedded the thing so we
have this crazy system today and so the
thing about free markets as you know
always turns scarcity into abundance
we've seen what we used to call
cellphones you know the first one from
Motorola thirty years ago big as a brick
weighed like a brick big as a shoebox a
40 minute battery life first one $3,995
now they're billions of them around the
world they almost give them away
depending on the plan you have
smartphone hundred dollars about to go
down to fifty dollars scarcity into
abundance how do we get that in health
care we outlined some of the basic
reforms one would be nationwide shopping
for health insurance instead of having
all these state cartels have hundreds of
companies compete for your business
equalized tax treatment if they're
self-employed and businesses get a tax
deduction why shouldn't the patients and
individuals have it or have equalize it
how about transparency how about having
hospitals post prices and clinics post
prices for all their services so one
proton charges two thousand dollars for
an MRI another one 350 have transparency
how about having requiring transparency
on how many patients die from infections
received after they're admitted to a
hospital it's a national scandal no
restaurant could get away with that
Chipotle didn't kill anyone
thankfully but the stock and company
took a huge hit but yet thousands of
patients died unnecessarily in our
hospitals how about readmission rates
how about choice of insurance I don't
need pregnancy
services thank you very much but I'm
forced to buy them absolutely crazy and
do away with the individual mandates do
away with the employer mandates and
safety nets you can have more effective
safety nets such as high-risk pools we
have it in food put aside how food
stamps are administer but no one needs
starve in this country you have a food
stamps you have food banks government
doesn't run agriculture has already
involved too much in agriculture but it
thankfully doesn't run it if a
government ran agriculture we'd have no
more obesity we'd all be starving so
it's happening unless you work for the
government but that's that that that's
what happened in Russia in China so you
can have a real entrepreneurship
effective safety nets and healthcare
taxes you all know this is the second
big reform price and a burden is that
not just raising revenue we're overtaxed
and the biggest abomination is the
federal income tax code you know the
litany Abraham Lincoln's Gettysburg
Address which defined the character the
American nation all of 272 words
constitutional amendments little over
7,000 words the Bible took centuries to
put that together 773 thousand words
federal income tax code and all the
attendant rules and regulations over 10
million words and rising nobody knows
what's in it as you know you call the
IRS hotline if they deign to answer it
for the third time they give you the
wrong answer money magazines several
years ago did a survey gave a
hypothetical family's finances numbers
to 46 different tax repairs people
considered an expert in the field got
back you know what they got back 46
different returns 46 different estimates
of the families of tax liability
thousands of dollars of difference so
the answer is the answer is we got to
jump this thing it is beyond repair and
I don't used to say we should bury the
thing but I'm not sure the EPA would
allow it to be buried now it's so toxic
but and and and and replace it and
replace it with a simple flat tax just
throw the whole thing out have a single
rate generous exemptions for adults and
for children and the plan we outline in
the book first 50 of your family of four
your first fifty two thousand eight
hundred dollars of a salary free of
federal income tax only 17 percent above
that no tax on savings no death taxes
you should be allowed to leave
unmolested by the IRS do the same thing
in the business side reduce the rate
from 35
17a Vincent's expensing of capital
expenditures and just do it and if
people say oh why not just throw him a
bone and have two tax rates or three tax
rates as some of the Republicans
proposed no you don't we should have
learned from 1986 when we had a little
bit of simplification got it down to two
rates 28% 15% ladies and gentlemen when
you put two tax rates together it's like
putting two rabbits together they breed
they multiply and and and and and you
saw what happened with that so let's
just go to a single rate and this is and
forty countries have done this and
jurisdictions have done this and that
and and and the real the real thing is
this is a moral thing think of the
opportunity costs the IRS estimates we
spent six billion hours a year filling
out tax forms experts estimate we spent
two to three hundred billion dollars a
year conforming with this monstrosity
just go back 20 years add up all the
tens of billions of hours trillions of
dollars all the immense brain power and
this useless corrupting complex activity
and think if that had gone to new
products new services new medical
devices new cures for disease how much
better and richer our lives would be set
a source of corruption that brings out
the worst in everything the third big
reform it's not the most exciting thing
monetary policy it's not fifty shades of
gray it's not like going naked in the
jungle it's not not the most exciting
thing in the world but it's absolutely
crucial why is it crucial because this
is how we make progress in the world
transacting with each other interacting
with each other buying and selling with
each other we do it billions of times a
day money makes that interaction easier
the progress easier to achieve rather
than trying to do barter money think of
money like you would a claim check you
know go to a restaurant during the
winter you check your coat you get you
get a token piece of paper a piece of
plastic in and of itself and is
worthless but it's a claim on a real
product money's a claim on products and
services and it works because it's based
on trust
so money measures value the way clocks
measure time scales measure weight
rulers measure space and so the thing is
it works best when it has a fixed value
think of it matching the Federal Reserve
was in charge of the time Bureau and
they decided a flow
the clock save this 60 minutes an hour
one day 48 minutes the next 96 minutes
the day after you know life would be
chaotic imagine if you go to the
supermarket want to buy pound of cheese
the pound of changes each day you buy
Bank gallon of gasoline you assume the
amount of the gallon is don't not
changing each day
so imagine baking a cake under this new
regime it says bake the batter 30
minutes you have to figure out those
nominal minutes inflation-adjusted
minutes are they a DC minute in New York
minute a Mexican minute be chaotic but
that's what they do
investing is risky enough but if you
don't know what you're gonna get back
100 cent dollar au cent dollar dollar
$10
it hurts investment which is the key to
future prosperity and so the fact the
dollar may be going up or down it's like
a clock that or a watch that's either
too fast or too slow neither one's gonna
help you very much
the Federal Reserve today and we outline
in this book is acting like the Soviet
Union that thinks that control the
economy by trying to control interest
rates and trying to control money it has
been as Donald Trump would say a
disaster take zero interest rates take
zero interest rates that is price
controls you know better than anyone
else what rent control can do and what
price controls to do to deform a market
they've done it to the credit markets
they made it very easy for government to
borrow very cheap for big companies to
borrow but small and new businesses
households let me just give you one
statistic in the past five years between
20 2009 2014 credits the government grew
37 percent credit to corporations 32
percent credit to small businesses and
households 6% absolutely pathetic on the
environment we have today especially
with hyper bank regulation very
difficult very difficult for small
businesses to get reliable lines of
credit which is why Apple 200 billion
cash goes out and borrows tens of
billions in the bond market why because
they can it's cheap so they buying the
stock rate for Apple shareholders but
not very good use of capital Exxon just
originally borrowed twelve billion
dollars to buy in stock and pay
dividends not the best use of capital
ultimately we have to go to a gold
standard why because gold keeps its
intrinsic value better than anything
else we did it for a hundred and eighty
years when you see the price fluctuate
that's the dollar fluctuating not the
intrinsic value of gold Gold's like a
ruler
like 12 inches in a foot or 60 minutes
an hour fix it have a fixed value like
16 ounces in a pound and you'll see this
economy start to really prosper in the
meantime since that's gonna take a lot
of intellectual work to get that done
even though we did it for a hundred and
eighty years in the meantime let's have
real interest rates in the market again
instead of these mandarins and
bureaucrat sitting interest rates let
the price be set by people free borrows
free lenders set that price and reduce
the Federal Reserve's obscene portfolio
nearly four trillion dollars which they
seized from the economy seized those
assets returned that let that flow off
as these bonds mature into the financial
system and have free people determine
where the capital goes and creating
future prosperity for all of us thank
you very much thank you Steve Steve I've
heard you say many times that monetary
policy is crucial and I've also heard
you say that when people start
discussing the topic that's usually a
signal for folks to either go to sleep
or leave the group and you know your
exposition with you know good humor
common sense is really really great and
I think I think it helps a lot of people
get the message George please join me in
offering a warm welcome to George
well thank you it's great to be in the
Hayek auditorium my the quote at the
beginning of the scandal money is from
Hayek and it says the root and source of
all monetary evil is the government
monopoly and control of money and this
is the part of the message that Steve
just gave and it's the heart of the
message of the scandal of money and but
Marx thousands
redefinition of economic statistics goes
deeper than even he has fully explained
I think because his key thesis is that
goods and services are not final
products the final product is the human
being and his creativity and the image
of his creator those are the final
products and they are measured through
information theory as knowledge wealth
is knowledge professor at MIT recently
summed it up better than I did I think
he said that when an expensive car that
says our hidalgo is his name and he said
when an expensive car crashes into a
wall all its value disappears even
though every atom and molecule remains
value is information that's another
Hayek point the car is knowledge and I
say all wealth is essentially knowledge
as Thomas auld put it the Neanderthal in
his cave had all the material
resources we have today the difference
between our age and the Stone Age is
entirely the increase of knowledge but
this gives us a further insight because
if wealth is knowledge what is growth
I've been studying business progress for
years that through the leading
consultants in Boston I I spent a lot of
time with Bain & Company and they have
documented learning curves all across
the economy from everything to rumba
eggs two insurance policies transistors
to software code and learning curve
ordains that with every doubling of
total units there's approximately a
twenty to thirty percent reduction in
cost so learning curves are ubiquitous
across the economy and so knowledge
wealth is knowledge growth is learning
that's what it is
and this is the real these are the real
final products their knowledge and
learning and knowledge and learning does
not happen only in the consumption of a
hamburger the consumption of the
hamburger the consumption of housing the
consumption of transportation clothing
whatever it is all in dowse human beings
with the capability to create to learn
to expand knowledge to expand wealth so
this is the this is what geo represents
geo represents all that learning at
every step in process it's not
restricted to the final output it
proceeds through the entire economy of
learning and knowledge but if
learning is growth and growth is
learning and knowledge is wealth what is
money and this has been quite an enigma
for me for a long time and I've been
somewhat distracted by various commodity
theories of money that believed that
somehow money is really the value of
money stems from its value is jewelry
you know gold is valuable because it's
really jewelry
thus money is valuable because it's
really jewelry well my friend Richard
vigilante said no jewelry is valuable
because it's really money and why is
money valuable money is valuable because
it's time it represents time in the
economy and when you have zero interest
rates for example you essentially are
zeroing out time everything slows down
a Jim grant describes it as throwing
away the clock in a basketball game now
everything slows down nobody scores it's
so everything slows down when the value
of when interest rates are zeroed out
that money is time it's what forces
entrepreneurs to allocate to prioritize
to invest and one thing rather than
another without interest rates you have
just everything can go forward because
with infinite time everything's possible
and this is really the vision that
currently governments the Fed so this is
why the return as we say to gold is so
critical because it because gold is
really time buy happens
fans throughout history the mining as
mining gear has advanced as the
technology for extracting gold has
advanced the gold has become more widely
distributed more attenuated and and
deeper and so essentially the costs the
time to extract the gold has remained
reasonably constant for centuries so
gold has thus become the source of time
in the economy measured through time and
and this is really the heart of of what
money is money is time and and what we
really are experiencing today is a war
against time
conducted by all the central banks of
the world and it explains the great
slowdown in growth that really began
with the abandonment of Bretton Woods in
1971 when every when we entered the mole
as decade and and everything began to
slow down because the signal of which
Hayek insisted upon was critical of the
price signals conferred by money were
debauched
and money became rather than a measuring
stick as Steve describes it it became a
magic wand and all these magic wands for
the government and all these and you
can't have real growth without knowledge
and learning and knowledge and learning
depends on real information rather than
on on the spurious manipulations of the
Fed who try to essentially try to fool
entrepreneurs into making imprudent
decisions so
but when we say going to the gold
standard we aren't necessarily speaking
about going back to anything this is
going forward the gold standard in
conjunction with the new global economy
opened up by the internet is is a
uniquely powerful new element in the
history of the world the the Bitcoin
blockchain
transforms not just the potential for
global money but also the the potential
for innovation in security you know the
Swift Network got crack got hacked this
the Swift Network is the central nervous
system of our banking of our banks and
it and it got hacked 60 million dollars
extracted in Bangladesh and the
centralized model of security is
bankrupt it doesn't work any more than
the centralized model of money can work
and the Bitcoin blockchain imparts
security not through concealment and
centralization but through transparency
and distribution you know you have to
hack half the computers in the world to
take over the blockchain and change the
public ledger of transactions so we can
now integrate a gold standard with a
Bitcoin standard which is explicitly
based on time and they converge and
provided that damn furniture wins this
fight to stop title to a domination of
the internet reduction of the internet
to pathetic public utility we're
aggregations of lawyers converge at
every node and control and specified
prices which is the meaning of title to
Internet it provided we preserve
a global internet and allow it to
prosper I believe that a gold standard
can evolve even if we can't go back to
the camp Gingrich VIN Weber gold
standard legislation that was introduced
in 1984 and which was the last great
hope for actually enacting a connection
between gold and the dollar so money is
time and time is real and time can't be
manipulated it can't be hoarded it can't
be redistributed it is time is what
remains scarce when everything else in
capitalism becomes abundant but the
abundance of capitalism is contingent on
the integrity of the information that
governs it the knowledge the processes
of knowledge and learning that underlie
it and embody it so I think all that
this introduction of the gross output
model is crucial because not so much
because it shows that consumption
doesn't drive the economy human
creativity drives the economy and I
think that is a tremendous insight and a
tremendous advance thank you
thank you George one of the quotes in
your book I have to paraphrase but it's
uh it's a paradox that's always puzzled
many of us that that so many who see
themselves as adherence to free markets
accept central planning in the monetary
wrong it's really really incredible and
the extent we can can convince people of
that paradox and inconsistency I think I
think it will help our cause we want to
open it up to questions often when I met
presentations at Cato the moderator says
they're going to invoke the moderators
prerogative and ask the first I'm not
going to do that out of consideration to
the audience I'd like you to have
opportunity to ask questions so those of
you who do ask questions please be as
considerate of your fellow audience
members and be concise please wait to be
called on and recognized wait for the
microphone so that the folks up here can
hear you and folks listening on the
Internet can hear you as well
state your name and affiliation and
please offer a concise question that's
actually in the form of a question so
why don't we start start right here in
the front thank you all for your
comments I want to talk about healthcare
my name is Lou Galliano I'm an advisor
to the Leapfrog Group I agree with you
mr. Ford's that transparency of prices
is important but frankly outcomes of is
is equally important and frankly more
important in my view to the care of
patients in particularly hospitals so
the question I have for you and some of
the things that we're seeing is that
actually some of the payers private
insurance companies are actually
promoting and sending patients the way
the best care is given without
interfering with the clinical decision
of doctors believe it or not so the
question I have for you is could you
comment on the fact of outcomes measures
being important to the decision as to
where we send our patients for care I
think the the way that you you phrase
the question where we
and patience in a true free market
patience would quickly have the
information on where best care is
available metrics would be created to
give them more sophisticated information
on particular outcomes what's happening
with breast cancer is a scandal what's
happened in terms of people dying in
hospitals because of infections received
at the hospital that are avoidable is an
absolute scandal so rather than hoping
the insurers getting the light like they
did a few years ago with electronic
records I mean every business in the
world has had electronic records your
local dry cleaner for 20 years for 30
years the reason because a third-party
payer you didn't you didn't get in
health care and then when they did it
they did it soviet-style sort of one
size fits all and it's been a disaster
so I think the key is all the proposals
we should make is how do we empower
information and patients to be able to
make more decisions and then providers
will quickly adhere to it and if they
don't people won't go there they don't
have to go there they don't have to be
directed there and that that is truly
the way to go instead of a top-down
saying okay let's have outcome oriented
markets will do outcome oriented very
very swiftly because of because again
health care is so personal and I'll just
give you one example I mentioned about
breast cancer there's a chain in
Pennsylvania called Geisinger several
years ago they put in the equivalent of
a warranty legally they can't call it
that but in effect if they bought your
knee operation the next one's on them
under the normal system we have today we
go back to paying it even though was not
done right the first time
how many Hospital chains have put in the
equivalent of warranties oh you can
count them on a single hand whereas in a
normal free market that would be quickly
imitated or you wouldn't get the
customers so let's get the patient in
charge and I think a lot of these things
we find desirable like electronic
records and better outcomes would would
happen naturally as they do in people
because it's it's about them the only
place warranties exist in healthcare
today is that if they amputate the wrong
arm
they will amputate the other for free or
operate on the wrong side of the brain -
yes sir the gentleman in the middle
there thank you max Pappas one time Cato
Institute employee currently economic
advisor at Ted Cruz George in your book
I thought one of the most interesting
parts of it was about the
financialization of the US economy and
what that has meant to the triangle of
how you described at Wall Street Main
Street in Silicon Valley and its
implications for economic growth could
you talk about that a little bit please
nope well I think the ultimate scandal
of money is what is used as the
alternative to the gold standard that's
floating currencies and floating
currencies today and there will be a new
accounting and this next month or so
from the Bureau of International
Settlements but to the latest estimates
are five point two trillion dollars a
day this is 26 times all of global GDP
it's 73 times all global output of goods
and services
it's a scandal and it's all conducted by
about ten banks they conduct 77 percent
of of this currency trading and it's 98
percent is speculative it can it's just
a complete failure the Chinese are
accused of manipulating currencies
because they refuse to float they fixed
on the dollar thus enabling their
miracles of economic growth and and
what's happening is this did this we've
created a closed loop economy with
between the Obama administration and the
Fed and essentially start up small
businesses Main Street has been shoved
aside and 62% of the feds money creation
back to the Treasury the other of the
other two-thirds most of it goes to this
carnival of of big companies buying up
their own securities for stock market
cosmetics and or buying up their rivals
of theirs as they're now twice as many
IPOs and China as there are in the
United States this is a real catastrophe
that's why we need a big change right
now the gentlemen near the rear peter
ferrara Heartland Institute national tax
limitation foundation I would like to
hear from Steve Forbes and George Gilder
about what are the concrete steps policy
steps that need to be taken to restore
the gold standard if you were advising
President United States what would you
tell them that needs to be done
step-by-step well the first thing is
that they want to do it and and then
they the other thing is will they know
how to do it under the Bretton Woods
standard we didn't which is why we ended
up wrecking the system and falling for
the false god that if we manipulate
money we can get easy prosperity so you
start right away by freeing interest
rates now they say Oh that'll disrupt
the markets know the markets already
disrupted just remember Peter Ludovic
Earhart
in the late 1940s is an economic
director in occupied Germany and
overnight he proposed doing away with
rationing they said that's a disaster
the Americans said it would be a
disaster and Ludvik Gerhardt replied my
advisers tell me the same thing it'll be
a disaster he did it anyway freed it up
and within days the shelves of a German
store started to fill up with products
and food and the German miracle began so
free interest rates at the beginning the
other thing is to announce that and that
and make it the case that that's
positive for the economy because then
you can get credit markets starting to
work again second thing is start winding
down the feds bloated
portfolio let those resources go back
into the free economy where people can
determine where they should go rather
than the Fed determining where they
should go and then on the gold standard
you could say by date certain we're
gonna fix it pick a price 1,100 1,200
and then then make it very clear that by
pulling away regulation right now with
banks you try to make a loan today you
have to justify it six ways to Sunday we
deregulated the transportation system in
this country in the late seventies begun
under a Democrat got to do the same
thing in the banking sector and now one
of the most wonderful things that
happened was Trump would call it
beautiful things that happened recently
was when the courts ruled in favor of
MetLife and all of those regulators who
had moved into MetLife had to leave
their free offices and the free meals
they got harassing MetLife in the name
of saving us from their depredations and
we we need to do that with the rest of
the economy because right now when the
Fed so cold what creates bank reserves
doesn't get multiplies that did you know
the old monetary theory just gets a
sterilised so start with those and just
announced a date certain both on
interest rates and on going to gold and
then in terms and then the other thing
you can do Peter is remove all the
barriers to alternative currencies tax
buries regulatory barriers food so that
way if the government starts to
misbehave you can do it and if somebody
comes up with something better you know
but the government can't block it so let
human ingenuity unli get unleashed there
and who knows what'll happen if I knew
it would happen I'd be on the Forbes 400
list for rich people participated but
let let let the thing unleash remove the
barriers so the faster the better
it's not complicated just do it and I
think will be mostly pleasantly
surprised by how quickly we come back to
life against like water in the garden
plants grow and they have water you're
already at the top of the list with your
knowledge Steve I'd like to make a
comment on that because I think from a
practical point of view setting a
specific price for gold would not work
I disagree with Steve a little bit on
this I think it should be used as an
indicator as to whether we're too
inflationary or too deflationary the the
idea in monetary policy is to provide
stability that's you're you you want to
provide basic stability and Milton
Friedman's monitors rule was was with
that goal in mind the problem was you
what is what is the money supply that
was his biggest problem because with
deregulation is that M 1 M 2 M 3 & 4
pretty much decided on M 2 and as a
matter of fact M 2 has been moving
relatively stable over even throughout
the financial crisis of 2008 which is
which is quite interesting but the
biggest problem is so I like to see gold
as an indicator you use it as an
indicator if it's drifting upwards that
suggests maybe too much inflation you
need to pull back but one of the
problems Steve with the fixed price is
that then if the price falls below the
price then you should be accommodating
and the Fed should be expansionary the
problem is gold is constantly
overshooting one way or another so you
become expansionary and then gold goes
above your market price and it shoots
way above it and then your restrictive
then you move it back down again
hopefully you would come toward a
stabilizing point of view but the
problem is the overshooting problem with
gold gold is not directly de tied only
to the dollar it's also tied to other
currencies so the volatility of gold is
a problem with setting a specific target
price which is a move unfortunately a
moving target it's a moving target when
you have floating rates and a non gold
standard you never had the problem under
the classical gold standard you never
had the problem under Bretton Woods when
they're behaving by the rules you fix
the thing and if other currencies
fluctuate it's because they're
misbehaving which is why under the
classical standard when people saw how
well it was working for us and for the
Brits they all adopted their own
of it so you had very little volatility
no need for George's a currency trading
so the volatility comes from the lack of
having asbestos asbestos if ax T and in
terms of trying to control the money
supply its I just think it's
preposterous it's sort of what you might
call the restaurant theory of economics
or a coat-check theory of economics a
restaurant owner notices that a
customer's check coach which means
they're more customers so he feels if he
creates more coat checks
that'll stimulate the production of more
coats and therefore more more people
come to the restaurant now it's
backwards money reflects people
producing products and services not the
other way around that's where Keynes was
profoundly wrong and you just look at
velocity what they call velocity of
money all over the place so get get get
it fixed like 60 minutes in an hour and
the hour won't fluctuate anymore it's
now the viscosity of money this was this
was Friedman's big big error I mean he
did believe that velocity was
essentially a constant and and
monetarism only works on the assumption
that velocity turnover of the money can
be predicted but turnover is controlled
by us by all those gold people producing
general output and and that can't be
controlled by the Fed by the way in
terms of marks thing an even better
thing there's a gross domestic
expenditure you should read his paper on
it which gets some of the flaws of the
ghost standard you would talk about gde
mmm-hmm which is even better than Gio in
terms of measuring yeah what my new
introduction to the structure I go into
how to take advantage of that yeah sir
gentleman in the front row Austin
Middleton from George Mason University's
University economics department
my question is Gerald a Driscoll here at
Cato has no fan of centralized monetary
authorities him a pines that even if you
set strict constraints upon the Monetary
Authority you can have serious problems
when the fiscal Authority is relatively
unconstrained and that this is he lays
the problems of the European Central
Bank down to precisely this issue so
given that you impose the constraints of
a gold standard upon the monetary
authority I suggest that you are curing
a symptom and not the underlying problem
which is fiscal profligacy well that the
Europe's problems are structural fiscal
and regulatory and the idea that
manipulating money like mint limit
manipulating the number of minutes in an
hour
is going to a cure those structural
problems is is preposterous
they can't Illinois if you take the word
Greece and translate it into English you
get Illinois and and and but no one
suggests seriously that if Illinois left
the dollar zone that its problems would
be cured let's have an Illinois peso
no that would compound it so just goes
right there though those are structural
problems nothing to do with the well the
euro has been mismanaged but the euro
and of itself is not the problem but
trying to use the euro to overcome these
structural problems not to mention the
idiot tax increases they put in in
Greece and elsewhere is the real problem
just as in this country so having having
a stable measure of money is you having
an unstable measure of money's not going
to overcome the problems you have of
hyper regulation over taxation and all
the anti growth you know they talk about
Obama's will of Obama talks about
Republicans war on women
how about President Obama's war on
prosperity which is the real problem so
having a steady measure of something
making an unsteady is not going to cure
those very real structural problems that
the Driskill and others refer to and I
would I would add also that issue
swelter de Soto in Spain has made a very
good point about this that the euro is
acting like a gold standard and so it is
it is causing Greece and other countries
who are fiscally irresponsible to suffer
as a result of this and get their act
together that's what the gold standard
does when you
over-over use your debt and tax system
and and the euro is is the gold standard
and so a lot of economists by the way
argue that one of the reasons that we
that they note that the countries that
went off the gold standard first during
the Great Depression recovered more
quickly it's an interesting argument
that is worth looking at and I think
that's what Greece is thinking of
thinking oh we can go off the euro and
therefore we can recover more quickly
that's that's the basis of that argument
by the way on thinking that unsteady
money works just ask Brazil how well
that works
Argentina how well that is works and Bob
we well that has worked countries that
have steady currencies do better over
time than those that don't have steady
currencies not to get in a discussion of
the depression but those who cheapen
their money all that did was get a
bigger than neighbor policy going where
they all went off all to botch their
currencies and the 30s overall was a
miserable decade you can cheat get a
little get a little leap forward then
others follow and you're back to where
you were
it's a it's a mistake anyway to think
that the key function of money is to
register something called inflation or
deflation it's to give signals of
information and in Europe it's the Euro
isn't gold the euro is a manipulated
currency dominated by socialists a
socialist regime and so it's falsifies
the information that guides
entrepreneurial creativity and that's
why it doesn't work it's not because of
that it will misjudge collective level
of prices which is almost impossible to
compute compute anyway all you have to
do is look at the price of oil the
nominal price of oil in the 70s when we
went off the rails went from $3 to
almost $40 a barrel because the prices
nominal prices going up people thought
we're running out of this stuff you had
huge investments and alternatives he had
huge investments in the energy industry
the early 80s the terrible inflation's
conquered all crashes down to $10 a
barrel Texas goes into depression the
agricultural economy goes and do a
depression unstable money and we saw the
same thing in the last decade unstable
money is like a virus in a computer it
corrupts the information Georgia's point
I think we're gonna leave it there
because I usually eat lunch at noon so
right now my stomach feels like I'm
living on the 75 minute hour that Steve
referenced earlier but I want to say
that one of the things that Steve
started out with in his remarks we kind
of reject this idea that we've somehow
got to get used to a reduced level of
growth the reduced level of prosperity
because the fact that we're living
through this difficult time really is is
a result of serious policy errors that
are all related to a reduced level of
freedom so obviously something that we
believe very strongly here at Cato I
want to thank you all for being here I
want to especially thank
those of you in the audience who are
sponsors of Cato it's your generosity
that makes our work possible and
especially want to thank the three
presenters today all of whom have books
available outside for for purchase I'd
encourage you to do so but gentlemen
thank you so much for being here
[Applause]
yeah
report